[Music]
Mickey klovski thank you for joining me
from Tel Aviv how are you good how's it
going thank you for having me brother uh
thank you for being your brother what
you've done over the last 10 days have
been utterly inspiring I've been H it's
been exhilarating watching H this this
idea that just started with a a message
in our friends group that said hey guys
we're Gathering a bunch of volunteers to
do something for this war some fullstack
engineers and product managers I
remember that I remember that link
because I think I was maybe a member
number 20 something in this group and
that's I'm going to hold to that that
number for a long time because now it's
it's in the thousands and uh what you've
done I think in 10 days is is really the
the essence of what it is what is the
startup nation and what is
entrepreneurship and how you create an
environment in which people all over the
country come together it's been really
incredible um watching it and and I'm so
excited to tell the story from from your
perspective as well as the impact that
it's had and where we are today so
Mickey take me back to to the morning of
October 7th you know what are what what
are you doing sort of in life in in this
morning and then where does this hit you
what's happening so um morning of OCT
oober 7th um I was in bed it was 6:30
a.m. um and we started hearing Sirens uh
because of rockets flying pretty much
over our heads in Tel Aviv um at the
beginning uh uh we realize something is
going on because you know chances of Tel
Aviv being bombed uh with that big of a
surprise are low so we uh opened up you
know the news and started pretty much
following what's happening it was you
know clear I got a video from a friend
of mine in the south of Israel uh with
Hamas terrorists pretty much in his
neighborhood with like a trank full of
kalachnikov weapons shotting at at at
pretty much everybody including
policemen's and Etc and it was clear
that something uh uh crazy uh is going
on uh we didn't know how big is the
scale of this massacre of these
terrorists that uh you know pretty
much went into isra and started killing
people but you know in a few hours we
realized how big is this you know the
rockets that were flying pretty much all
over the country uh uh the amount of uh
dead people the stories that were start
that started coming out from the party
uh um in the south of Israel and then
you know in that day I also realized
that a friend of mine uh from school um
at the beginning we thought she was uh
taken hostage in in Gaza but then uh you
know a day later we realized she was
dead she was killed uh by a terrorist so
you it it's it's a real nightmare what
happened on October 7th I I don't think
there's other way to describe this as a
as a holocaust scenes especially now
when you're hearing the actual the
actual stories and you know other than
than being called by the Army and and
the militaries and the reserve duty I
realized pretty quickly on my Facebook
feed Twitter feed Instagram how many
needs are uring are popping up from the
field uh all the way from the citizens
in in the south of Israel to people who
want to donate to uh uh um tack people
who want to volunteer so there was like
a lot of mass uh uh going on and I was
trying to figure out what we can do
about this and what I started seeing
over and over again is the need for tech
support in different places all the way
from the military to uh uh uh citizens
to volunteering groups to um uh any any
possible way that you know Tech can help
automate stuff uh um uh upgrade some of
the systems in place uh uh build some
systems that are needed but are not you
know fully functioning and etc etc etc
so I said okay let's start a group I
know a lot of people you know coming
from the tech industry I'll just gather
everybody I'll try to build a process
where I can just connect match this
Market Place of one side of volunteers
and from the other side the needs uh uh
from the field we started uh uh on on
Sunday so the the attack was on Saturday
we started on Sunday so I I guess around
you know 1 p.m. we had the first 2030
people um and then you know we just
started sharing this pretty much
everywhere but also started uh working
uh um or trying to work with with
official authorities to get all of this
supply of volunteers into work uh I
think the first uh project that came off
of came up off off of this group was
like a project that was gathering a lot
of information of the missing people
because there were a lot of uh uh
Missing Personnel all the way from the
party to people that were you know
taking hostage and Etc so there was a
lot of need in aggregating data into one
API uh um doing uh facial recognition
all this kind of technology to pretty
much help everybody just understand
where people are because there was a lot
of mess in the south of Israel and then
from there it just started exploding uh
we started with like two three managers
what soal of this operation now we're
almost 30 um all the way from people who
are uh um um doing the uh uh the
authorization into the group because we
want to make sure that no enemy uh like
uh um people are in the group uh um and
are exposed to what we're doing and on
top of this uh uh we're doing a lot of
work in terms of
matching between uh um you know the
volunteers and the projects so far we
did wow I hundreds of projects it's
extremely hard to track because some of
them are just connecting you know
software Engineers to like a specific uh
organization that needs tech support uh
um to helping you know kibuts in the
south of Israel that needed some it work
like everything you can think about and
uh now we're officially 1500 people
which is a lot of people we started with
just a few dozens now it's 1500 people
and we're about to double this by
merging with another organization that
does the same a lot of our work by the
way
is to try to clear uh the communication
and make sure that people are not
working on the same thing uh um and
there no duplications because that
happens a lot and people really want to
help but I've never seen in my life the
amount of of urge from people to help
and to you know do whatever they can do
to help this country uh uh fight back
this is this is insane and so so so much
inspiring it's it's crazy tell tell me a
little bit about how that evolved so
that that this idea that okay we have we
we have these needs that are coming up
they're they're coming up sporadically I
guess throughout different different
channels and different organizations how
do you explain what's happening here you
are you're experiencing you you're
effectively becoming the platform for
people to to be able to provide this
help and support as sort of the the
person overseeing this plat platform you
you've seen it from the beginning H how
do you explain what happened here so you
know one of the hardest parts about
building a process in a mass is that
nothing is uh uh predictable so the
needs are changing constantly so it was
hard for us even though it's been only
10 days but it was pretty hard for us um
to figure out what's a process that
would work so we realized that a lot of
the needs that are coming from the field
are extremely hard to explain so we have
somebody that actually listens to anyone
who wants to get volunteers and help and
get help with tech because some of them
just are not techy but they know they
need some kind of automation they know
how to explain you know Basics but they
don't know they don't know how to
explain like that they need a front-end
engineer or like a devops they don't
know what it means so a lot of this we
have a person Omri our friend who's
pretty much listening to each and every
one of these people so you realize that
there's a gap already that there's
organizations that need some support but
they don't even know what to ask for but
they know that they need something they
need it urgently and you need somebody
who can under who can sort of be this
this this Matchmaker between what their
needs are and then what what types of
people do we need in order to fulfill
that role exactly and then you have this
and then you have authorization you need
to make sure that you're you're doing
all the uh all the tracking and making
sure that you have all the database
written because when you want to connect
some body to a frontend engineer you
need to make sure that you have an
available frontend engineer at any given
moment that we can connect to and then
we have a whole process of working with
like uh we have Elan who's working with
Gil Gil is coming from uh the IDF I know
her from the IDF uh from theal She's
connected to the you know the the the
formal uh Connections in in in the Army
and other places we have Elon who's
working with other organizations for
Partnerships uh we have p and Ben and
Orit who are taking care of some of the
ongoing processes so we do have like an
actual operation just to clear
communication and make sure that we are
actually connecting people as fast as
possible and things are happening
because what happened at the beginning
is that I opened the group as like a
chat group so everybody can talk and you
know I need this and you need that and I
realized that very very fast but people
don't know how to explain what they need
that there's a lot of mass tons of
duplications and if we don't manage the
process properly we won't be able to
grow this into something meaningful uh
uh because you need to make sure that
people trust this channel as a channel
to get volunteers as a channel to
connect with projects so that was a lot
of work but but again you know it's not
and and it's not me there's a whole
operation here A whole group of amazing
people were managing this but a lot of
the stuff are changing constantly and
that's the challenge the challenge is
that you know one day you need a lot of
uh uh help with hasbara one day you need
a lot of help with uh with the U you
know crms and stuff like this for like
for volunteers can find you know
donations like every day there's
something new and there are other
projects which I can't really talk about
but they they do a lot of impact pretty
much all over the internet in terms of
you know defending our citizens content
wise there's there is a lot of work
there um one thing that you can see is
that it's pretty clear in the war there
are many battlefields there is the
battlefield you know ground with foot in
the ground but there is De bottle field
online which where every war we have a
problem with every war there's
lies um uh uh spread it all over the web
uh about how Israel behaves where we are
what we do what our values and I think
this time there's a lot of focus on
trying to btle this back and to fight
back on this front and we are doing
everything possible as well to be able
to provide any technological aid to any
possible organization in no time
literally takes and I I I can there's
one thing that I'm pretty proud proud
proud of is is that it takes us I guess
like five minutes to match somebody uh
with an organiz literally like five
minutes where you know taking the phone
up we're doing the match we're doing the
making sure that the the connection is
right we're making sure that they know
how to uh um support each other and
let's go and we can do that over and
over and over and over again on scale
which is pretty amazing
how how did you how do how do you
explain getting so many people not only
involved with their own
personal um their personal passions and
their personal abil abilities but you've
also mentioned that you qu within 10
days you grew this from having two or
three managers to having 30 managers so
how do you how do you even fathom you
know what happened here from an
organizational perspective or or an
operations perspective you know how how
did you manage through that and and what
were sort of the incentives
here
the I mean you want to protect your own
land that's pretty much the uh the
incentive right now there is no in
there's no it's not like a business
thing um you know we have 30 we have a
core of 10 managers and then other
managers who are helping us with like uh
um you know other processes um they just
really want to be a part I'm getting
messages so my WhatsApp crashed three
days ago um two years of data uh just
deleted because my WhatsApp was pretty
much
bombarded with any possible message you
can think about with people who want to
volunteer and people who need
volunteers um and and you can just see
it every message says I'm willing to do
whatever you need 247 to help you guys I
do x y and Zed I'm a tech guy I'm an
operations guy I'm an HR guy I'm
whatever I'm here to do that because
everybody feel like this is this is one
of the most important words in in in
Israel's history um in no other country
in the world it's not even surrounded
you know our enemies within us there
there's absolutely no land on planet
Earth that has this and and everybody
feels that it's time to it's time to
fight back it's it's literally there's
no better time to do that were were you
personally always this passionate about
this uh I mean I mean I I mean every
Israeli is is passionate about this
you're passionate about this we're all
going to the military we're all going to
we're all protecting Israel 24/7 when
there's no war as well when we're
talking to people and people are
criticizing us we know how to protect
ourselves it just you know the urge is
Big there is war outside I hear bombings
all the time Tel Aviv is feeling this
very very hard not as hard as the south
of course you know I'm coming from
ashalon um I was born and raised there
so for me there's no question you just
do that um and I mean there I don't I
don't think I was B passionate about
this but I I just I feel like I have to
this is this is it what was the most
inspiring moment for you looking back
for a second in those 10 days you know
you've been I know you've been 247
crazed and working around the clock to
get this to to get this to um height
that I don't think anybody could ever
imagine um H what if you look back what
was one or two really sort of inspiring
moments where you said back and said
whoa okay this is this is cool this is
this is
incredible I think
every every message we're sending in you
know in our what's so called newsletter
our WhatsApp announcement group and
every every call we're making is is
inspiring you hear people no matter how
old they are where they are what they do
they're willing to stop whatever they're
doing right now and to volunteer
on an extreme scale on an extreme scale
like no matter what they need to do
they're willing to do that and that's
extremely expiring that it's extremely
inspiring and that's why I why I'm doing
this every day it's everything you know
it's helping the police it's helping the
the formal authorities it's you know
there are many many projects I can't I
just can't you know share but it's it's
helping it's just making sure you have a
very trusted source of an extremely
large group of people who are willing to
do whatever they need to do to protect
the country um and and that these people
even though they're sitting at home and
they're not whatever on
duty they're stopping everything and
they're focusing on this and they don't
stop until they they make it um I I
think the most by the way maybe my
personal most inspiring moment was I
didn't know I it was extremely hard for
me at the beginning and even now it's
extremely hard to track who's working on
on what because people are changing all
the time changes are changing all the
time needs are changing sorry all the
time um everything is pretty much very
Dynamic and then what I realized is one
one of the projects that I wanted to
connect I started calling F like you
know very close friends of mine uh uh
engineers and some of them a lot of them
said I'm already on another project and
in this group and I was like okay the
impact is huge because they already
working on something else it was pretty
fast with found somebody to do the the
product that I was looking the people
for but it was amazing to see that all
of my friends are volunteering within
this initiative and my brother uh uh
joined he's in North Carolina right now
he's not in in he lives in Europe but
he's not in Europe right now he's
extremely you know careful about Israel
and he stopped all of his work and and
join volunteering and helping me manage
this group it's just it just in I can't
explain it's there's no words to explain
how amazing is this to see you know so
many people want to be part of something
so big it's um i' I've been getting um
so inspired by this um you know I had I
had the privilege of of seeing it from
from just start and and I saw the
explosive growth and what inspired me
most was just watching how effortlessly
this Grew From 20 to 50 to 1,000 to now
1500 and now the now another merge and
and I saw how effortlessly that was and
I think that's the beautiful part in it
for me that is the essence of what
happened here that's the depiction of
how how Israel's best and brightest with
different disciplines this is not just
Engineers it's not just product managers
you've invited people from all walks of
life with all different disciplines if
you look at the group
description I remember on the third day
you started listing the different types
of people that we have in the group that
can support and you see anything from QA
to to AI computer vision research to
graphic design to and and it's just
awesome really is awesome have calls
from like you know teon PhD groups who
are looking to to volunteer some of the
brightest Minds in this country are part
of this and this is super inspiring I
just I I really want to say as well if
you have friends in the uh United States
who are connected to somebody in Israel
who's in Need for any technological
support anything uh we're here to do
that I'll add the link they can just
sign up we'll make sure that we reach
out uh um we're trying to be very very
very clear about what kind of projects
we promote and what what kind of
projects we don't promote because some
projects are also filtered out um but we
do everything possible to match in a
super fast way
um with people uh who want to help and
and I think this is amazing and I want
to say because I know they will be
listening to all of my friends managers
uh who are part of this so David Orit uh
pel Ben Omri everybody else I I I pretty
I'm pretty sure I forgot uh some of the
names but just you guys are rock I I
love you thank you so much for taking
part thank you so much for jumping on
calls all the time pretty much 24 seven
thank you so much for taking this so
seriously I appreciate it so much it's
there's absolutely no way to describe
the amount of gratefulness I have for
these people this is amazing I love it
the Gratitude is just shining through
here and I think that's part of the
magic of what what you created and who
you are personally Mickey love you
brother thank you so much and thank you
for inspiring
[Laughter]
me